voilà on peut en parler est ce qu'on
peut en parler au président de la
république pour ce qui pour qu'il
intervienne
est ce qu'il est possible d'intervenir
en chine on sait que c'est compliqué
mais aujourd'hui ce qui se passe en
chine
c'est inadmissible c'est très grave est
vraiment c'est très grave tout ici en
france il ya de plus en plus de gens qui
sont en train de se mobiliser et qui si
on parle et qui ont envie de faire
passer un message mais le seul qui peut
faire quelque chose aujourd'hui c'est le
président de la république emmanuel
macron est ce qu'aujourd'hui je suis sûr
qu'ils nous regardent les manuels
battront jeu persuadé qu'ils vont nous
regarder
est ce qu'il est possible de lui faire
passer un message par votre billet
puisque vous n'êtes pas de paroles de
gouvernement et d'essayer de faire
quelque chose au plus vite à semblerait
que la biélorussie que des we go alors
il n'est pas normal de faire passer un
message
parce qu'il est totalement au courant de
la situation et qu'il est totalement
mobilisé sur la situation des migrants
moi je fais des médias toutes les
semaines personne ne pose la question
mais sinon je peux vous dire très
clairement un que le président l'a dit
il a écrit et je le redis ici
la france elle condamne ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui avec les ouigours c'est à
dire que c'est parce qu'on l'a pas dit
des camps d'internement des exactions
des violences sexuelle et reproductive
du travail forcé on va de la survaleur
de la surveillance de masquer les qui
sont les ouigours 1 pour nos
téléspectateurs et voilà qu'ils sont ce
qu'ils sont et ne seront pas au courant
c'est vrai que elle en parlait il ya un
instant c'est une communauté musulmane
donc en en chine et c'est vrai qu'ils
sont persécutés sais vous allez vous
l'avez dit c'est une épée c'est une
évaluation sur les choses c'est c'est
joli c'est c'est une horreur ce qui se
passe ça fait longtemps que ça dure ça
fait longtemps que ça dure
et là et c'est inquiétant moi je le dis
ceci sur enodis magasin mais c'est
inquiétant quand même que ça soit des
gens qui mettons la larme sur sa
auxquels les journalistes n'ont pas posé
des questions mais des fois vous êtes
des adultes pouvaient aborder le sujet
de vous même comme je vous dis pas que
on met la larme alors c'est justement tu
es la largue larmont la sécurité des
nations-unies la larme on l'a depuis
longtemps encore le cjp ameco france
s'est dit alors à tanger 10,1
je le dis on condamne et quand la france
dit qu'elle condamne quelque chose ça a
quand même un certain poids dans le
concert international 6 la deuxième
manche mais le conseil de sécurité tous
les organismes des nations unies
évidemment qu'on les saisies évidemment
elle fonctionne au brigandage à la fois
mais à chaque fois que la france en a
l'occasion
dans ces réunions on demande à ce qui
est des condamnations qu'ils soient
faites et à ce que les actions qu'ils
soient prises achats
fois que les pays proposent intègre le
domaine des parfums hors pair koh-lanta
bas je peux dire que je peux vous dire
que dans le dans dans ces organismes
on le demande à chaque fois que des pays
qui propose un texte global de plusieurs
pays pour condamner prendre des mesures
ma la france est le signe elle essaye
d'avancer
donc ça veut dire on le fait à chaque
fois qu'on a l'occasion d'avoir des
échanges diplomatiques avec nos
homologues ou avec des responsables
diplomatiques chinois on a ce message là
deuxièmement et troisièmement est
aujourd'hui une chose sur laquelle on se
mobilisent parce que ça l'état peut le
faire directement
c'est aider les ouigours y en a pas
beaucoup mais qui sont aujourd'hui sur
le sol français parce qu'on a parce
qu'ils ont besoin d'avoir un titre de
séjour
parce que pour ça ils ont parfois besoin
de passer par le consulat en chine que
ça peut être très compliqué et donc on
fait des facilités pour permettre de
renouveler leur titre de séjour
ceux qui sont sur notre sol pour le coup
on sait ce qu'on veut faire avaler là
bas le drame il a donné dix mille et la
maman ici en france il ya plein de
choses à faire avec les marques le
devoir de vigilance mais que raphaël
glucksmann essaye de faire voter en ce
moment la commission européenne fin
c'est quelque chose c'est d'obliger les
marques à arrêter de faire passer des
classes que le seul truc qui peut
marcher avec le gouvernement chinois je
pense c'est mine dingue les impacts et
économiquement c'est sur ces ses avances
à cesser serait la solution oui dieu
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire clairement
pour que enfin qu'est ce que le
gouvernement français peut faire
clairement pour que tout ce qui se passe
là bas ça s'arrête quoi alors je pense
déjà que le gouvernement français seul
savait compliqué justement et abriel à
thales qui est pas possible d'aller voir
peut-être l'allemagne va l'aider je ne
leur a pas exactement au nom de l'europe
donc d'aller voir angela merkel le voir
ce qu'elle en pente parce que si déjà
toute l'europe se mobilise et
économiquement et c'est d'un pacte et la
chine
je pense que il va quand même avoir une
écoute
voilà parce qu'aujourd'hui je vois je
sais ce que faire appel demain dès 10h
bravo à lui parce que c'est vrai qu'il a
pris ça à bras le corps et c'est vrai
que aujourd'hui si on ne sait pas d
impact économiquement je vois pas
pourquoi ils nous écouterait les gabriel
thales que vous avez des jeunes là on
leur parle de l'europe
on leur dit c'est un continent on a des
valeurs ça de mâcher si dans ces moments
là l'union européenne ne parle pas d'une
seule voix
comment vous voulez a marqué la jeunesse
dans l'espérance d'une union européenne
qui est porteuse
je sonnais pas capable de le faire je
totalement d'années qu'ils y croient je
suis de cette génération qui a grandi en
entendant en permanence que l'europe ça
marchait pas et que ça pouvait rien
faire mais on le démontre un accord sur
le sujet à une question sur sur ce sujet
là mais ce gars mais on se bat pour
essayer de ramener des pays autour de
nous ça se fait pas en un claquement de
doigts et je pense que ça payera
je pense que ça finira par payer
deuxièmement cette crise si on revient
sur le sujet d'avant je veux bien rester
sur ce sujet mais cette crise a quand
même permis de montrer que l'europe elle
pouvait faire des choses ce qu'on a
réussi à faire tout à l'heure on en
parlait sur le plan de relance c'est à
dire avoir une europe qui lève de
l'argent qui développe ses propres
ressources pour venir en aide aux pays à
ses états membres
c'est totalement de windows accord sur
le remboursement de la dette mais ce
n'est pas d'or il ya quelques années ça
aurait été jamais envisageable jamais
les pays membres de l'union européenne
et notamment l'allemagne n'aurait
accepté ça parce que président s'est
mobilisée depuis trois ans qu'il a
travaillé là dessus et que ça porte ses
fruits aujourd'hui qu'on est capable
d'arriver à ça et moi je suis persuadé
que sur des sujets comme celui qu'on
évoquait sur les migrants ça finira par
payer ça finira quand il y en aura plus
que ça va servir mais là il ya urgence
il est mignon je vais vous dire c'est un
peu le sentiment que ça donne que si
c'était une autre communauté qui étaient
touchés
je sais pas moi peut-être on en parlait
des chrétiens d'orient moi j'ai été
touché de ce qui se passait pour les
chrétiens d'orient
moi je trouvais normal qu'on aille les
défendant leur secours pour les sauver
de quai ici même pas un sujet
la question c'est qu'on se dit là voici
une communauté musulmane sommes fous
donc on va laisser faire non mais c'est
l'impression que ça donne mais je
l'entends avec la même force légale
manière donc contre l'injustice pas
contre une ou pour une communauté en
particulier contre l'injustice c'est ça
la grandeur de la france c'est vrai
reconnaît justice la layan mais où là il
ya urgence
il ya urgence gabriela talent